we have two very special guests and
adjoining Maurice Jennifer that's right
we have two members of the u.s. chess
women's committee and two friends of
mine
Maureen Agra Maude and Kimberly ado
McVeigh and they are with Maurice indeed
a lot of things going on in women's
chess
these days it's certainly an
international level as we see at this
tournament and definitely here in the
United States and two women who are
leading the charge marine Agra Maude of
us Chester the chair of the u.s. women's
chest committee and Kimberly do McVeigh
marine I'll start with you first of all
how excited are you to see a tournament
like this here in the US the strongest
women's tournament ever held on US soil
well I have been giddy since I got here
so I have just I've been over the over
the moon with what has happened here
today and I'm just so thrilled
especially to hear the responses of the
players and why they came in and what
they did to get here and so we're so
excited to see that so we're shedding
light on women around the world not just
including in the US but around the world
and to see them here on American soil is
just incredible it's just a dream
Kimberly I know you have daughters in
chess or is it one daughter to daughter
and two daughters that play chess and
also a son what was your experience like
seeing your daughter's playing when
we're not that many role models here in
the u.s. we certainly had our players
but what what was their experience like
and you as a mom seeing your girls play
I think of all he had a really positive
experience playing against the boys and
also the few girls that were that were
on the circuit and I think that now
looking back they see that or they they
now realize that chess played an
incredibly important role in their lives
and they've benefitted greatly from it
have you been motivated at all by the
difficulties that young girls have faced
in chess over the years to be a part now
of the u.s. women's committee
oh definitely I think that girls are
becoming stronger and I think the fact
that our committee and it can can
support them has just been something
that's helping to just grow the number
of girls in the chest community Marine
what's your experience what you've been
hearing out in the field is the the
challenge of growing girls and women's
chests what have you heard and he's the
scholastic level etc well since since I
came on board four years ago chairing
the committee the the thing we needed to
hear was from the ground level what's
happening in the fields and finding and
hearing from the parents the players as
well as as well as the coaches all
uniform all said the same thing and that
is why can't we get more girls to the
game what can we do to get more girls
and and tell us please show us how and
so in those four years we have developed
and tried to tap into what makes girls
tick as opposed to what makes boys tick
so girls think you know they when they
play the game their game after the game
they love to socialise they'll get
together and they don't necessarily and
some I mean there are players that do a
you know play competitively but the vast
majority of them they afterwards they
want to come around and they want to
socialize over the game and just be be
friends and and so this is these are the
things we wanted to accomplish is to
bring these girls from all around the
United States and just see that there
are other girls playing chess and that
you have there's a sisterhood there now
there was an announcement yesterday that
$100,000 gift was being given by the
club to the committee that must have
really warmed your heart yes very much
so
a little bit yes very very much so and I
can't think enough to Jeannie and Rex
Sinquefield for doing this through
through the st. Louis chess club and
this is just incredible to me it's like
I see not to us it's the icing on the
cake of what we've accumulated trying to
do in these last several years to bring
up the level of women and girls chess
Kimberly you come to a tournament like
this one how does it motivate you to do
this work and what lessons you feel
you're gonna take back for fruitful
discussions with the committee well
first of all I had never been to st.
Louis before
aside from layover at the airport and so
to come here and see the st. Louis chess
club and see the Hall of Fame
it just it's to me it's like being at
Disney World almost just because there I
think there's so many people don't
realize that st. Louis has now become
such an important hub for chess and now
seeing the Karen's kept going on and all
these incredible female chess players
coming together I think that just also
makes me much more motivated to get
girls more involved in chess
Maryna give you the last word how can
people find out more and offer their
assistance to what the work you guys are
doing well we're always looking for
donations and volunteers and just a
growing base and there is a growing base
throughout the United States but you can
go on the US chess website under the
Women's button Women's Initiative and
underneath that there's everything from
articles to tournaments to anything that
you want to know about women and girls
chess and weight and when I say women
and girls we mean all ages from two to a
hundred and two fantastic well keep up
the great work
Maureen gramado and the Kimberly do
mcveigh of us woman's chest committee
doing fantastic work enhancing
everything here we're doing at the club
fantastic work again go to the website
us chess org and you'll find out more
that's right and you can actually go to
us chess women org just to get all of
that information right I actually had a
question for marina and Kimberly first
of all thank you both for your
leadership and all that you do for chess
it's very inspiring to hear you speak
you were talking about the social
aspects there of chess and girls and I
remember during the US Women's
Championship playing with Maggie Maggie
thing bughouse and all the girls were
getting into bughouse
so variant where you have to have a
partner it do you find that perhaps
might be more inspiring for for girls
that they could play team chests
very glad you brought that up because
that's exactly what we're we're trying
to encompass in the growth of girls and
women because for females they do like
to socialize so if they come together as
a team
even if one player is not as good as the
other and and we've actually discussed
this in our committee and that is get a
mature player when I say mature I mean
it doesn't matter age it means a
stronger player with somebody who's
brand new somebody new fresh fresh out
of the you know out of the outside of
the chest community to come in and play
on teams and they mentor each other and
do it the same with partners so that
becomes a a team effort and this way the
players that are that don't know much
about chess they learn from their
partner and vice versa and it becomes a
social like a sisterhood type type group
and social gathering and afterwards yes
you're right
usually afterwards there we have a girls
club room at the national tournaments
and they're out there analyzing games
but they're also painting nails and
putting little chests little diamonds on
their on their fingernails you know it
could intimidate the boys when they're
playing on the board what's your
experience Kim with your girls do they
do
things like that when they were playing
chess there was no such thing as a girls
club room when my girls were playing
chess unfortunately but I do think that
they you know they they all liked having
the idea or liked having a team of their
friends playing together and they would
like to socialize at the tournaments
unfortunately there weren't that many
girls playing and I do think that they
having the girls clubs room club rooms
have been have been pivotal to making
the girls feel like they're more welcome
at these national silastic tournaments
yes that is one thing we have noticed is
the retention they keep coming back
because they want to see their
girlfriends their times they were
a-changin thank you so much for your
work